là ça bouge devant l'immense ce plaisir
et honneur de recevoir katell qui sera
ce soir au portobello pas loin ici à
20h30 pour célébrer votre nouvel album
que moi je considère comme un des
disques de l'année je le dis franchement
il y avait 15 bresson melody nelson il y
avait les j et k tél j'ai adoré cet
album
il fait suite à la disparition brutale
de votre maman il ya un an et vous avez
travaillé autour évidemment du thème de
la disparition du deuil mais sans jamais
tomber dans le pathos en août touchant
énormément de comment vous avez fait
quand je travaillais seul droit j'ai
travaillé seul pour faire pour élaborer
la musique du disque faire les
arrangements jusqu'au mixage
effectivement et c'est vrai que c'était
le sujet était plutôt plutôt lourd mais
mais le mon sentiment c'est est en tout
cas quand on quand on vit quelque chose
d'aussi intime que le deuil c'est en
même temps la chose la plus intime et la
plus universelle de soi
dieu
et
vous avez travaillé seul mais sur scène
vous ne serez pas seul nom sur scène
alors j'ai fait un gros travail de deux
voix sur l'album dans cette cette idée
les jcc un poème antique c'est un
problème grec qui célèbre justement les
morts qui célèbre valax le poème du
deuil mais par contre il ya cette idée
toujours d'avoir d'en chercher des grecs
soccer c'est cette voix qui vient
consoler ou qui vient parler avec avec
avec le personnage principal sur scène
de qui à nathalie rey o qui au clavier
et au coeur diane sorel qui au coeur et
aux petites percussions claire joseph
qui est au club de coeur et mon hommage
très cher ce cahier que j'ai avec
laquelle je travaille depuis très très
longtemps on a commencé ici à caen à
faire des groupes ensemble et elle m'a
rejoint la sueur c'est sûr c'est que je
me souviens c'était en 2001 au zénith de
caen avec deux lignes avec un certain
bezos
il
oh
jouer ici un compte sur vos terres ça
vous fait quelque chose de particulier
c'est une question qu'on pose souvent
artistes qui reviennent mais oui oui non
mais oui parce que je sais qu'il va y
avoir des gens des gens à qui je suis
jean très précieux pour moi que oui oui
non mais à tous les niveaux et puis
c'était évidemment la ville où vivait ma
ma mère donc forcément c'est une
résonance particulière ici
voilà l'événement ce soir à caen c'est
aux portes au vélo avec la présence de
katell à partir de 20h30
on va tout de suite au mémorial pour un
spectacle musical autour de ce qui s'est
passé dans l'été 44
venez
c'est comme ça qu'on me
moi qui suis né
les deux colons
petit rené à 17 ans et veut s'engager
dans la résistance
la comédie musicale 1 étaient 44 raconte
le 6 juin et la bataille de normandie à
travers le destin de jeunes gens pris
dans la tourmente des événements on
parle pas d'un bouquin on parle d'un
vrai sujet est quelque chose qui existe
et c'était pas en noir et blanc c'était
vraiment c'était la vie et c'est pour ça
que c'est intéressant
choisir de
hommage aussi aux roches en belles ces
femmes engagées dans des unités
d'infirmières pour libérer l'europe en
s'imprégnant de tout en fait des
témoignages là nous on va voir toutes
les villes tous les endroits on
réfléchit aussi ce qu'on aurait pu faire
nous mêmes cette époque si on s'était
retrouvé cette place là
je regarde
j'accorde
sinon
la fédé
l'idée c'est de ces justes de raconter
de parler des victimes civiles de parler
de tous ces gens ordinaires qui sont qui
sont aussi voilà témoins victimes
charles aznavour le parolier claude
lemesle jean jacques goldman ou encore
maxime le forestier ont participé à
cette création
c'est pas une comédie musicale sur la
guerre un spectacle sur la tête sur la
libération
c'est ça qui est très important à dire
comme un mère m'a toujours dit que plus
beau jour sa vista la libération
varilhois chrétienne que jamais elle
avait connu une joie appareils
la comédie musicale en étaient 44 et
présenter toute cette semaine à travers
la région avant le spectacle en
intégralité au zénith de caen et roman
la saison prochaine